- C'est la fin d'une longue
dont 57 enfants à bord de
ce bateau.
Ils ont tous été rescapées
d'embarcations de fortunes
de la Libye. Ils sont par
la suite restés trois semaeses
sur le Ocean Viking dans
ces espaces restreints.
en Italie. C'est finalement
en France, à Toulo q qu'ils
ont pu mettre un pied à terre.
Ils ont été tr
vers un ntntre de vacances
transformé en centre d'acceuil.
- Dans
déjà tous un kit nourriture
quleles attend, qui permet
justement de pouvoir lesananana.
- Ils sont originaires
de nombreux pays tels que
la Libye, le Tchad, le Nigéria,e
d'asile sera étudiée au cas
par cas.
CAMILLE CHAIZE, porte-parole,nir
- Effectivement, il y a
un contrôle important de la part
de police aux frontièreonononon,
l'état civil, la nationalité,
est-ce qu'ils sont mineurs
ou majeurs?
- Le ministre depapapapapapapaps
l'Italie.
GÉRALD DARMANIN, ministre
français de l'Intérieur
- L'Italieinhumaine dans cette ,
les autorités italiennes
ont été, par ailleurs,
non professionnelles, elles
on
sans décision ce bateau.
- Ce geste aura
des conséquence : La France
compte resserer le contrôle
de ses fpapapapapapapapapapapape
du parti d'extrême droite,
Manene Le Pen réclame
le renvoi de ces migrants.
- Il faut que ces navires,
lelelelelelelelelelelelelelelelt
en mer, les ramènent à leur port
de départ.
- La première ministre
italienne, Giorgia Meloni a
déno
Son pays a accueilli,
cette année,
près de 90 000 migrants,
clame-t-elle.
Pour l'instant,
11 pays européens ont cecepté
de collaborer avec la France
pour acceuillir les migrants
acceptée.
Ici Marie-Isabee e Rochon,
Radio-Canada, Montréa